this comic has been dubbed one of the
funniest on the internet
huh and that's the toughest comedy crowd
of them all
welcome to the bananamore stage a little
gentler here
caleb here on
hello wow what an honor to be here
no please stop cheering it's too much
you guys are too much
you're too much hi i'm caleb um you guys
already knew that i know you're looking
at me and saying
he's comedy's bad boy
he's a playboy millionaire
philanthropist who's constantly doing
good and making the news
and these things are true about me but
i'm also
i'm also a bodyguard for hire and
there's nothing funny about that to me
there's nothing funny to me about
protecting lives especially of those
who have money and fame the most
important people
we agree in our society and you know
what
why am i a good bodyguard uh because
number one i'm gay
and people would think oh maybe that
doesn't make you a good party it makes
you an incredible bodyguard because i'm
naturally suspicious of everybody i meet
okay i doubt everybody from the start
and to the end
does that i hope that makes sense and
also i'm fat and tall i'm big do you
understand what i'm saying i'm
if you took a picture of a normal person
or the body of a normal person
and then you're pretend you're god you
click shift and then you just drag it
out from the corner and it goes like
that that's my mass
that's my surface area okay to use a
science term scientists in the crowd
make some noise
oh one in the back so if i'm your body
guard and i have to dive in front of a
bullet for you or dive in front of a
knife for you
or dive in front of a rotten tomato for
you i don't know whatever you have going
on
there's a better chance that i'm going
to catch it with my
flesh for you do you understand what i'm
saying
now i before you hire me as a bodyguard
which you're all going to be begging me
to beating down my door i want to let
you know that i have a very impressive
resume okay the most important
bodyguarding job i've ever done was in
january of 2014 when i was in college at
missouri state university
two brags right he was in college in
2014
not that long ago right and then also
that i went to missouri state university
harvard of southwest missouri everyone
please you guys stop
stop cheering as loud as you can okay
aaron carter came to my campus and my
friend doyle and i
were aaron carter's bodyguards for the
night that he was on campus
now why were we chosen to do this you're
asking it's an unpaid job no one
said that he even needed security we
kind of made the jobs up ourselves why
did we get the ability to do that
because we were on student activities
council what is student activities
council well
student activities council is the thing
you do in college when you're not having
very much sex
so you've got time to kill and you plan
events for other students who aren't
having very much sex
because the people having sex aren't
coming by the way well oh
so
[Laughter]
they're not coming to the event they're
not attending the event
we all okay so it was a difficult job it
was a lot i mean
you know we were sweeping campus which
just means we were walking around
talking into walkie-talkies
about nothing by the way nothing's going
on normal day on campus aaron carter
comes he performs at the student union
the girls are ravenous they're trying to
get to him 22 year old girls are
obsessed with him because they thought
he was cute when they were 12.
anyway we protected him we saved his
life basically
and then he lived to tell the story he
popped up on tmz a few weeks later
wearing a sweatshirt from our campus
and he kissed my friend grace weird
choice weird or cool you decide
round of applause anyway it is i'll
decide what i'm saying it's a little
weird
and then he posted a picture of me on
his instagram after the show and said
look at that security guard in the front
straight g though
and if you're asking yeah i hate that he
talks like that i do
think yeah it would be good if he didn't
speak in that way
straight g though coming out of his
mouth not comfortable
you know what i mean anyway if you guys
need a bodyguard please hit me up
that was bananas i want more thanks for
coming to bananas
[Applause]
[Music]
more